So I would to consider with you one example of
what Rice's Theorem might mean in practice
and  might not mean in practice,
and the example I find very illustrative for this is
malware detection,
so determining if a program does something bad on your computer
or if it is a harmless program that you want to run.
So first of all, we have to think of it about
what actually classifies a piece of software as malware?
So a good classification of malware be that
it's a piece of software that does something the user doesn't want it to do?
Would it be a good classification if it deletes files?
If it gathers information from your computer?
If it disrupts or interrupts other programs?
If it installs itself or something else without asking you as a user?
Or some combination of the above.